[Music]
hi there and thanks for joining us I'm
reto Meier and I'm Stephanie many of us
are reaching for hybrid cloud nirvana
which makes the workplace mobility
between on-premise and cloud computing
ideal for our work to help us navigate
through this we welcome hen goldberg
engineering director for Google cloud
nice to have you here hi thank you very
much for inviting me absolutely hybrid
cloud is a common strategy that
businesses look to modernize while still
supporting their current applications
how does Google cloud approach this
particular challenge so first of all
it's important to understand why
customers one or more than ice and what
they are looking for that and the most
important thing is for them to in order
to compete they have to increase their
developer agility and have them to be
more focused and they really want to
take advantage of the amazing
capabilities that are available in the
cloud and using new cloud services but
they have to make a decision and it is
because they cannot modernize everything
at once that's one of the concerns the
second thing is that they also have
concerns from regulations that require
them to stay on premises so from their
perspective it is a reality that hybrid
is here to say and they have to choose a
hybrid strategy you know to modernize
and advance their business for us in
Google cloud we understand that way to
support our customers in their journey
okay and our goal is to make sure that
we help them reduce the risk instead of
increasing the risk when going through
this journey and risk are coming in
different different levels for example
and not fragmenting your talent and
lying to create a consistent experience
everywhere and also really leveraging
the existing assets you have today so
not asking them to buy a new soft a new
hardware for example but really blending
in to their existing environment and how
does this truly differ from other hybrid
offerings Google puts the user at first
in the center and we understand that our
customers appreciate to have choice okay
they want to be able to choose where
they're going to deploy their workloads
what kind of tools to use which services
to use and our goal is to make that
possible while reducing risk we do it we
do it by building our platform based on
open source technologies which are
ensuring that their workers are portable
and we are not
locking them in and we're also now
approaching multi-cloud strategically
and giving consistent experience
wherever customers choose to deploy
their workloads
now that's amazing what components make
up anthos and how do those components
work together to provide a really
integrated approach for our customers so
others is a opinion platform managed by
Google in the foundation in the core of
it we are using open source technologies
originated by Google like kubernetes sto
and key native but this is not
sufficient for a customer to manage
their trigenics environments they have
on top of that we are building a multi
cloud multi cluster control plane the
threads our customers connect to all of
their environments and manage them in a
consistent through a single pane of
glass we also give them tools to manage
policies and control in all of those
environments but not everything is
containerized and this is also about
investing with what they have today so
on top of that we are creating a service
management platform which allows them to
connect all their services because of
what the compute there is and on top of
everything we have an awesome
marketplace that allows us to provide
both first party and third party
applications available in all of those
environments so you just mentioned
investing and what our customers are
already using today
how can anthos be used to help them
modernize in place so what we hear from
our customers that when they come and
they want to use new cloud services they
have first to qualify and make sure that
the cloud meets their bar right let's
say they want to use bigquery or even
gke they need to go through the specific
process usually manual process to make
sure they can let their developers use
it with GK on Prem they don't need to go
through that process because we bring
this technology into their datacenter
and they know it meets the ball so
that's actually the fastest way for them
to innovate that's great what about
config management with anthos how can
you write multi cluster policies right
out of the box so that's a great
question I think that the number one
concern that CIOs have is how they
manage risk and specifically how can
they make sure that they know who access
what resources
and making sure that they know what
policies are applied everywhere and when
you have more and more environments you
have to build more and more tools and
have more people managed it so anthos
config management allows you to manage
those policies from a centralized place
and even if by accident or by a
malicious user someone is trying to
break that policy automatically we will
apply that policy and bring that
environment and it back to be compliant
ok so more environments more tools can
you elaborate on what we're doing to
give users the visibility they need so
that they can see what's happening
across all these environments yes so we
are leveraging open api's which allows
us to actually integrate with every
environment wherever the user chooses
and we are creating tools centralized
tools in the control plane this gives
you signals or monitoring data from all
of those environments in a consistent
way and we're also leveraging things
like key native we just announced cloud
run is beta to give a simple and
effective user experience for developers
again to deploy to all of those
environments so when I think about it
it's not about portability of workloads
but it's actually about portability of
skills can my developers can my service
operators use the same set of tools
regardless of which environment they
wanna use and by leveraging open source
technologies this is actually possible
no it's fantastic
I'm curious you know they're our
customers using anthos today and what
are some of the more interesting use
cases that you may have come across I'm
smiling because ever since we've
announced back then it was CSP eight
months ago is alpha we've seen an
overwhelming excitement with our
customers over 1,000 customers showed
interest just during next to try out CSP
anthos and we see different type of use
cases so I would say for someone like
HSBC they were excited to give their
developers platform on modern platform
without having to go through all the
qualification making sure that the new
environment means about so they're doing
both but they know that for some of the
workload they will have to stay on Prem
they will see other customers like calls
for example it'll look
to innovate both on-prem and in the
cloud and create a consistent
environment and maybe talking about a
customer like KeyBank okay so they are
really excited about the agility so
really leveraging new tools and make it
that they can deploy quickly in other
environments so different customers see
different use cases to begin with but
they are all very excited by both
agility and reducing risk thanks for
walking us through the possibilities of
anthos thank you for having me
[Music]
you
[Music]